i'm going to show you some footage in a
moment of a man that murdered olivia
i'm doing this because people may
recognize what he's wearing
it may also help people remember
seeing him in the area
on the night that olivia was murdered
and thereby help us trace where he is
and where he went
we can play that footage now
this footage that we're looking at at
the moment
shows the gunman
running along finch lane away from
king's heath avenue which is of course
where olivia lived
you then see him turn right
into
berryford road and go out of sight
we know this man is climbing through
gardens and through people's backyards
in order to avoid being identified as
well as using the roads as you can see
you will see from the footage
that the gunman is wearing a black
padded jacket
a black balaclava with a peak
black gloves
and also has dark trainers with
distinctive white souls
he is described as approximately five
foot seven tall
and of slim build
this is the man we are hunting for
we need to know where he went that night
i need to know if you saw him in the
area
remember this was shortly after 10 pm
on monday the 22nd of august
now i know that there will be people
shielding him
and helping this man avoid
being found by the police
if you are found doing this then we will
do everything legitimately possible to
bring you to justice
it is beyond comprehension how anyone
could protect or harbor a man who's
responsible for killing a nine-year-old
child
this man is toxic
he is toxic to our communities
and if you're protecting him he's toxic
to you and your family
i want you to place the loyalty that you
have towards your family
above the loyalty that you may have to
this man
i want the information as to where this
man is